well hello everyone we're next session
in this most interesting congress
virtual Congress is on lipid
measurements and we have a world expert
to present on the subject of
interpretation of clinical laboratory
lipid and lipoprotein measurements who
is associate professor David Sullivan
he's from the university of sydney in
sydney australia and and he is also a
pathologist a chemical pathologist at
the royal prince alfred hospital in
sydney and he is going to speak on the
this issue and and we will be providing
the points of how can the laboratory and
the laboratory report achieve the
greatest value in and benefiting
patients and influencing patient outcome
particularly when a when when the
patient is being seen by a family
practitioner or a general practitioner
and so I'd like to welcome David and
hand over to you at this time thank you
David thank you very much had and good
morning everyone or I realize will be
different times in different parts of
the world and really grateful to the
organizers for providing an opportunity
to discuss these issues with you today
it's an exciting venture and I hope I
can provide some useful illumination
it's a little bit daunting because I
realized that different approaches are
adopted around the world this was even
evident as we prepare the slides and
you'll see that we work in SI units but
we'll try and convert to mass units
where appropriate to try and keep things
fairly familiar for people I've just
knows my disclosures there and I took up
how its challenged with a little bit of
uncertainty because
I feel that often we're in a situation
with result of lipid tests in particular
and maybe other tests in general where
we are provided with insufficient
clinical information on the request form
and that the most appropriate
interpretation of the results with
exercises such as calculating the
absolute risk of a cardiovascular
disease in the next period of time
requires more than just the lab results
and so I guess we prefer to
individualize the information and engage
in a patient-specific dialogue rather
than invest too much effort in a
generalized lab report which I think
sometimes clinicians find is less useful
and so part of our report form is really
often guiding clinicians to sources of
information or inviting them to contact
us to discuss the patient in greater
detail so let's look at a couple of
individual patients and and how Adam
what do you think of this particular
young lady right so this is a young lady
she said no clinical notes available so
we're not sure why she's presented to
her family practitioner but you one can
clearly see she has a very elevated
cholesterol we're at 353 milligrams per
deciliter her high density lipoprotein
cholesterol is quite adequate but she
also has this very high LDL cholesterol
of 275 milligrams per deciliter so David
I would see that this would she would be
at increased risk of cardiovascular
disease particularly because of just the
high LDL would that be an appropriate
comment or thought about about this
patient less interesting hard and look I
think maybe some of the issues that come
forward here are a fairly standardized
approach first of all which we can adopt
for all patients where I think we should
think about potential secondary core
the lipid disturbance in this case
predominant hypercholesterolemia yes for
treatment decisions we do want to tie
things back to absolute risk which of
course involves other risk factors
beyond lipids I think we've gone past
the days where we should put the HDL to
total cholesterol ratio on the form and
then quote a particular level of respect
in sufficient information to carry out
that exercise but I think the main issue
we'd like to raise here is that young
women are usually not at high risk of
cardiovascular disease in fact or
comment further about that later on but
in the situation the specific situation
of inherited risk with familial
hypercholesterolemia there is a risk and
we're very keen to flag individuals who
might have this particular problem so
looking at a standardized approach down
the left-hand side you'll see that I
think it just helps notionally at a
clinical level so think about whether
the patient has a predominant problem
with cholesterol or a problem with
triglyceride or a problem with both
energies of course many lipid disorders
are primary they're due to either
monogenetic or poly genetic influences
interacting with environmental factors
but I don't think we do have a
responsibility to think through and
consider secondary causes and for such
elevated cholesterol in this particular
young lady I think we'd be thinking of
issues such as hypothyroidism nephrotic
syndrome and college days is
particularly primary biliary cirrhosis
which would generate maybe suggestions
for further laboratory testing I think
we're keen for the clinician to try and
add in important information such as
clinical signs I agree with the
suggestion this lady might have familial
hypercholesterolemia it would be of
assistance in the diagnosis if the
clinician indicated whether they were
tendons and farmers there or
premature corneal arcus that would help
with the diagnosis I think we're beyond
the stage of the old friedrichsen types
in terms of trying to add diagnostic
information the Friedrich syntax are
really just a shorthand for which
particular lipoprotein is accumulating I
think the exercise is more about making
specific clinical diagnosis such as
familial hypercholesterolemia and then
assessing the overall situation in terms
of severity with HDL we can base
traditionally we've looked at LDL
cholesterol levels and increasingly I'll
make the case that we should be looking
at non-hdl cholesterol levels so here is
the exercise in maybe trying to work out
this person absolute risk of a
cardiovascular event and you would
comment that first of all this can be
done sometimes with charts which of
course sacrificed a lot of information
they they bundle a lot of clinical
information together so that we don't
have any degree of severity for the
diabetes we don't have any degree of
severity for numbers of cigarettes
smoked etc etc however these risks
calculators do make an approximation of
the level of risk of a coronary event in
Australian situations that calculations
over the next five years these
approaches also help with patient
education but the first thing you would
have to say is that that the the the
calculators are limited because of the
epidemiology which analyze them those
calculators did not really take into
account younger women and therefore our
calculator is only qualified to estimate
absolute risk over age 30 35 for some
population groups made
b5 for most of the population and
secondly I make the points on the bottom
right-hand corner that the number of
people with such severe
hypercholesterolemia and you can make
the same case for blood pressure the
number of people in the epidemiological
studies were small and therefore there
is a lack of certainty and therefore the
cases made that there are upper limits
to the risk factor levels for which the
risk calculator should be should be used
fits in well with the concept of
familial hypercholesterolemia because it
really is a special case it's a really a
common condition that's probably the
most common potentially fatal genetic
condition that we know about prevalence
of we think now about 1 in 250 its user
dominant mutations affecting the
function of the LDL receptor and that
brings about a near doubling of the LDL
cholesterol level in the plasma here you
can see the idea of the LDL receptor
capturing LDL particles internalizing
them the clip the LDL particle is broken
down whilst the receptor itself
recirculates to maintain cholesterol LDL
cholesterol uptake and so when this
process is interrupted it accelerates
the onset of cardiovascular disease by
about 20 to 40 years and poor detection
rates occur in many countries and I
think that's a real question for our
health services because this is a golden
opportunity to prevent premature and
avoidable cardiovascular disease and
just to convince you of the degree to
which it does accelerate cardiovascular
disease here you see men and women with
and without familial
hypercholesterolemia and it's taking a
horizontal line we compare the orange
men with nearly all hypercholesterolemia
with the turquoise ones without likewise
the women with their familial
hypercholesterolemia in yellow and the
green ones with our you'll see that
separation along the horizontal axis is
about 20 to 40 years so that's the sort
of impact that we're talking about a
best practice for managing this
condition is to try to depict as many
cases as we possibly can and when we
find the first case of family that's
called the index case and techniques for
doing this is the middle of the LDL
cholesterol and the other signs and and
clinical information that i mentioned to
calculate a score referred there are a
number of different scores we prefer the
dutch lipid clinic score and if it is
above a certain level it starts to
indicate that the presence of familial
hypercholesterolemia is possible or
probable or even definite and the
definite category comes about by the use
of genetic diagnosis sequencing as the
LDL receptor gene or other related genes
and that's what generates a definite
dissolve however the whole system can
operate without the need for genetic
testing it can be done purely on a
clinical basis and we prefer to think of
genetic testing in this situation is
more of a tool to assist the other main
strategy and that is the strategy of
familial cascade family cascade
screening and family castrated screening
consists of investigating the
first-degree and second-degree relatives
of the affected index case because
within about two years of investigating
such a family we find around about eight
affected individuals and another eight
people who can be reassured they don't
have the condition and once different
family members have been detected we
have guidelines for management's through
our whole of life and those guidelines
have been investigated and shown to be
cost-effective here we see that statin
treatment and this is over 12-year
follow-up that statin treatment was
reducing
vascular event rates by nearly three
quarters and around the 75 percent
reduction in event rates and another
analysis in the right-hand panel you'll
see that although these interventions
are a cost to the health health service
by the time you get out past about four
years as this sort of management plan
the reduction in events turns out to be
constipating so a strong encouragement
for us to do a good job of finding these
people and we've tried to to augment
this process in Australia through our
laboratory reporting system and through
the College of pathologists we've tried
to standardize a comment on high LDL
cholesterol results right across the
country and it's rather an interesting
saga because we did the we match the the
distribution of LDL cholesterol levels
in the community and the prevalence of
the condition and felt that we should be
flagging LDL cholesterol results greater
than equal to or greater than 65 250
milligrams per deciliter however when we
worked with our our clinical users GP
population they got very enthusiastic
about it and wanted to flag everyone
with LDL cholesterol levels greater than
5 so that was going to lead to a much
less specific and more sensitive but
this specific identification of patients
we felt that we had to go with a user's
advice so we've implemented the the
right-hand comment but we we were
worried that in fact it's going to lead
to a loss of specificity so we are
directing people to the website there
which will provide them with access to
the ducks look at clinics school of our
calculator and hopefully there
busy as and will be channeled in the
right direction different approaches
exist in different countries and one of
the features of familial
hypercholesterolemia is clear evidence
of vascular damage occurring at a young
age with these very high cholesterol
levels on the top panel you'll see just
the issue that in autopsies on korean
war victims many of them were in their
early 20s that the severity of already
established cardiovascular disease was
proportional to the number of risk
factors and in the bottom panel you see
into a medial thickness measurements of
patients with familial
hypercholesterolemia and you can see
that the affected population has
accelerated thickening of the carotid
wall indicative of early damage to the
arteries and so this has been harnessed
in the US with some rather controversial
guidelines have come out with the idea
of got so much necessarily of looking
for index cases but rather screening the
whole population at a young age ages
nine and 17 in other words either side
of puberty and universal screening with
the aim of achieving two outcomes first
of all detecting cases of familial
hypercholesterolemia and maybe then
doing what we call reverse reverse
cascade screening looking at whether the
parents of the children had a problem
and the second intention of this rather
controversial guideline has been that
it's aimed at also picking up the
metabolic consequences of the rampant
problem of childhood obesity so a rather
different interpretation of liquid
results in the u.s. in children because
it is recommended there's a universal
screening strategy so in summary I think
the important issue is to recognize the
clinical features and causes of primary
dis live ademia then
the recognition of familial
hypercholesterolemia and that we've got
important strategies such as flagging
very high LDL or non-hdl cholesterol
levels assessing the likelihood of the
diagnosis of the dutch living clinic
score and then following up with family
cascade screening where genetic testing
is a supplement that's not a necessity
so with that we might move on to a
different sort of case scenario how do
yes so here we have a more traditional
patient presenting with lipid studies
with a male who 67 years of age and has
a type 2 diabetes and just looking at
the baseline results it's evident that
this patient has an elevated
triglyceride at 264 milligrams per
deciliter and I think elevation diabetes
is a factor which gives rise to increase
triglyceride is that correct David yes
thank god yes I think if you like to
think of type 2 diabetes is fuel
overload I think macronutrients allow us
to have a fuel overload in terms of
other carbohydrate ie glucose or lipid
ie triglyceride and it's I think logical
then to realize that if you've got fuel
overload once you've got it in one form
looks likely which you might get it in
the other form as well and so not only
is high triglyceride associated with the
diabetic state but also think in many
cases an elevated triglyceride without
diabetes is a harbinger of future risk
and because that might often help to
motivate patients so once the
triglyceride is elevators I think some
of the other important consequences
arise as a result of an entity known as
cholesterol is to transfer the protein
and that might be worth a quick aside
here to say that we were developing what
we thought was going to be a marvelous
tree
for this situation we had drugs which
inhibited cholesterol ester chance their
protein and you'll appreciate from what
we're about to say that they did a great
job of lowering LDL cholesterol further
of boosting HDL making the picture look
much much better but unfortunately for
the third time in recent history a drug
of this type has ceased investigation
because of lack of benefits so
unfortunately we we don't have the easy
access what we were going to get just
around the corner however i will just
well this slides i'd make the point that
the typical picture in type 2 diabetes
is one of high triglyceride low HDL
triglycerides HDL often reciprocal to
each other and the LDL cholesterol
you'll note isn't particularly high in
fact it's at target levels for our
secondary prevention patients and so you
might ask the question do we need to do
anything about this this patients lipid
level and first of all its appreciates
wife actually happened to the lipid
level looking at the role of this entity
cholesterol is to check protein because
cholesterol subtracted protein really
just allowed lipids to swap between life
and protein particles and in doing so
the lipids just redistribute down the
concentration gradient so the
triglyceride rich particles particularly
very low-density lipoprotein vldl have
lots of triglyceride the cholesterol
ridge particles and he could have either
LDL or HDL rich in cholesterol so when
cholesterol ester transferred protein is
available it allows the swapping of
triglyceride for cholesterol and so if
we look in the bottom panel at the
cholesterol-rich particles they lose
cholesterol ester and have it replaced
by a triglyceride under the action of
CTP left-hand arrow between the orange
particles
right-hand panel you'll then see that
the triglyceride which is a fuel just
gets used up and therefore the particle
moves to a new state where it's actually
becomes smaller and and so this is the
process which brings about reduction in
LDL HDL cholesterol levels and the
production of so-called small dense LDL
for my HDL is probably largely due to
the fact that the smaller particles are
too stable and they tend to get
catabolized but in dland but in LDL the
particles are still stable they just
exist in this smaller dense estate and
just to reiterate vast here is another
example with the triglyceride which
particle on the left having the lipid
exchange and the cholesterol ester
transfer protein and then having the
triglyceride in the cholesterol-rich
particle concerns leaving a small
advanced particle this particularly
happens when triglyceride levels are
elevated that is causing a change in the
cholesterol content size and composition
and density of the cholesterol-rich
particles and in the case of LDL it's
making them smaller and denser but one
of the consequences of this is that when
triglyceride is elevated there will be
more LDL particles than you might
appreciate from the LDL cholesterol
level so that the risk is on a per
particle basis and therefore the LDL
cholesterol in this situation may
underestimate the risk and patient may
be under treated on their faces people
sometimes go to huge links to designate
whether a patient has the light fluffy
LDL or the small dense LDL the phenotype
a or the phenotype B but in many ways
it's simply a surrogate for the
triglyceride level at Eastleigh a plot
of increasing triglyceride levels of the
transition from the scene of phenotype
age of the phenotype d I think as
laboratories we can guide our users as
to when the efficient for the presence
of small dense LDL may or may not be
useful and in the process of a sense of
15 that scene attack the method often
involves gradient gel electrophoresis
that we come up with the diameters of
the particles however it should be
pointed out that that diameter looks
quantitative but it's really qualitative
it's just telling us whether the
particles are small or whether they're
normal size then it's not telling us the
number of particles and therefore I
don't think that the test in itself is
particularly useful in terms of the
final designation of the amount of risk
the issue of risk hinges purely on the
number of particle t you see from the
Quebec Heart Study in the orange bars
you see the comparison between large and
small LDL and provided there is no
increase in their number in this study
there was no increase in risk in the in
the back turquoise bars you see that
when there is an increased number of LDL
particles it is particularly harmful
when the particles are small and dense
probably largely because it's been
misinterpreted as not being as high as
people think it is and it's so small
dense LDL the main issue is is there an
increased number of these particles this
then causes some highlights the problems
I alluded to earlier as far as the LDL
cholesterol level is concerned so the
LDL cholesterol level when small debts
particles present is no longer
reflecting the number of particles
cherry will we can judge the number of
particles by the measurement of fo be
there is one fo b molecule to extragenic
particle and you can see the correlation
is only modest between LDL and fo b and
the discordance is really quite high so
it's over fifty percent so that's saying
that the the fo be the LDL levels are
scattered fairly widely around the fov
median now if we take the case of
non-hdl cholesterol which can be more
simply derived than LDL cholesterol you
see that insect the correlation is
better and the little of discordance is
less so this actually makes a case that
rather than continuing to rye and LDL
cholesterol we would actually do better
to move off in the direction of paying
more attention to non-hdl cholesterol
parham this has been borne out in
clinical studies and here you see the
degree of risk predicted by the LDL
cholesterol in the US health
professional study it's certainly
significant but it was surpassed by the
non-hdl cholesterol level which is
getting up towards the levels of what
we've seen by the preferred measurement
of nov so born out in looking at the
issue of discordant from the training
training him off spring study you can
see that in yellow when both the LDL
cholesterol and the LDL particle number
agree yes of course if the if the levels
are low for both then the risk is also
low but in what you see that if they are
discordant if the fill the old particle
number is still low but the LDL
cholesterol level is high the risk
remains low and conversely in the bottom
line there you see that if the LDL
particle number is high and the LDL
cholesterol is low that in fact survival
is worth so the actual clinical events
are tracking with particle number not
with LDL cholesterol content and finally
just to make another point as to why all
the old cholesterol levels may become
less may become less useful in the
future or less reliant upon this is
information from trials with very
aggressive cholesterol-lowering using
new therapies and you can see that the
calculations of LDL cholesterol level
using the feed world equation which is
our main relay message main method of
obtaining an LDL cholesterol that that
becomes very unreliable when we're
dealing with very low levels of LDL
cholesterol as determined by
ultracentrifugation and you can see from
the different colored bars there with
the green bar getting up to its button
to seventy percent difference that this
particularly happens when triglyceride
levels are elevated again an expression
of this formation of small dense LDL so
in summary I think we're looking at
declining reliance on LDL cholesterol is
the diagnostic threshold or treatment
targets and we're looking at maybe
replacement with the simple calculation
bond HDL less soul which is just the
total minus the HDL cholesterol simpler
alternatives that may offer a better
performance so maybe we sort of
sustained a little bit of that theme
with this particular case Howard we were
dealing with a non fasting state yes I
see this is a gainer middle-aged male
and non-fasting again triglyceride
elevated significantly elevated and the
cholesterol this time is also above the
desirable level but as you've reported
here that the LDL cholesterol is
unsuitable for reporting so could you
just explain that a bit further David if
things had yes so I suppose maybe the
note that the LDL cholesterol is not
suitable might imply that we don't think
we get much information out of a
non-fasting sample and would it be
easier for our patients if they could
avoid the need to fast for lipid
measurement so look I think there are
some pros and cons as far as that's
concerned the underlying problem here is
mixed hyperlipidemia and we need to deal
with out on its merits but I'm really
using this as an excuse to explore some
of the implications about long fasting
measurements and one of the first points
to make is that the non fasting state of
course is the state that prevails most
of the time in humans in our society
and therefore maybe not to measure
patients who have had a meal is is doing
them a disservice because it's not
reflecting their usual metabolic
situation and encouraged by this thought
maybe even encouraged by the thought
that perhaps therapist certain elements
in the in the postprandial state which
likely to promote artery damage the
group in Copenhagen have looked at
non-fasting triglyceride levels and they
looked particularly it levels around
about four hours after whatever the
recent meal had been and they find it's
actually quite sensitively predictive of
improving the top I think you see
females at the bottom you see men and
it's predictive for both myocardial
infarction ischemic heart disease and
indeed total deaths and and particularly
predicted in the case of women so not
fasting triglyceride level a strong
predictor of cardiovascular status in
women and so on the one hand we have the
fact that are fasting measurement avoids
the presence of chylomicrons and that's
an assumption that we make when we do
the feedwater calculation of LDL
cholesterol and secondly it standardizes
triglyceride measurement for the
diagnosis of hypertriglyceridemia
obviously we do need a degree of
standardization in that situation on the
other hand it's not the first the
failures of fast doesn't make that much
impact on the total cholesterol or the
actual ultracentrifuge LDL cholesterol
level all the non-hdl cholesterol level
it would just be recommending it does
make a modest impact on HDL cholesterol
the courses i think it's usually a
temporary decrease due to those exchange
processes we noted earlier and I've just
raised the issue that maybe it's a more
sensitive marker of cardiovascular
total mortality now if we were to take
the converse point of you and say okay
what about doing postprandial
measurements can we standardize those
measurements anyway I don't think so i
think we'd be looking having to look at
the composition and dose of the meal
we'd be looking at what its
physiological relevance was with Wonder
I think they're still be issues about
the background bias the gastric emptying
time after we've had a meal that be all
sorts of different time points we could
choose we could measure all sorts of
different parameters it would be very
difficult to know how to present the
data it may be worth just pointing out
that there are some specific markets
that that reflect some aspects of
postprandial metabolism would use
retinol ester levels in the past and
after arrest knowledge to load and with
we've also used the measurement of fo be
48 and I suppose these things could be
pursued if if we really believe that the
risk of artery damage is greater after a
meal certainly a time when there's a
flux of dietary cholesterol at time when
these competitions the LDL receptor we
see activation effective seven on the
surfaces of chylomicrons I guess the
main question is whether Carla microgram
blue ribbons can penetrate the artery
wall and the been quite elegant studies
looking at changes in vascular
reactivity after different types of
meals and i must confess that I think
the literature there tends to be a
little bit inconsistent so trying to
come to a final conclusion on these
things postprandial testing really is
that standardized in terms of the timing
for delay of gastric emptying at the fat
content of the preceding meal on the
other hand its lack of impact on some
parameters means that it is adequate for
assessment of total cholesterol and HDL
I think for the purposes of the
absolute risk calculations that we
mentioned earlier I think it's also
adequate for the calculation of non-hdl
cholesterol and we've already seen that
this is superior to LDL cholesterol
particularly calculated LDL cholesterol
so again and encouragement maybe that we
could think about using non-fasting
non-hdl cholesterol which is usually
around about point 5 to point eight of
the really wild the leaves are higher
than the LDL cholesterol targets and
cut-offs that we've tended to use in the
past and so maybe non-fasting examples
are adequate adequate unless we're
calculating LDL cholesterol or we're
diagnosing hypertriglyceridemia now many
of these come in so personal views and
people might want to take me up on them
on just some summarizing of thirst or
views that non-fasting liver the life of
praising testing may better reflect the
predominant metabolic state it may be to
reflect the antigenicity of the
postprandial state it may be sufficient
to derive total and hdl-cholesterol
absolute risk assessment it may be
sufficient to calculate non-hdl
cholesterol is a preferable measure of
atherogenic lipoproteins and it may be a
practical help in facilitating
management of individual patients saving
them for certain degree in inconvenience
so I don't know if you want to take me
up on any of those how did or move on to
another case now I think we'll move on
to the another case and once again
you've presented data from a middle-aged
woman and this time she's clinically
well and presumably has gone to a
medical family practitioner to get a
really a health test as opposed to a
diagnosis for any disease so she's gone
along and what we can see quickly
looking at this that the various levels
is that the LDL cholesterol is quite is
low at 19 milligrams per deciliter and
therefore one would take this woman is
very healthy from a cardiovascular
aspect is that the case David I think it
is the case
and and we'll go into some of the detail
however it's also been an area of
concern I think it it needs to be
acknowledged that illness in most of its
forms will be a secondary cause of low
cholesterol and so of course that's
generated concern that low cholesterol
might be causative of some disease
states and those ideas have been
expressed in areas such as the risk of
cancer and so forth however we do have
some interesting natural experiments by
way of genetic abnormalities and I think
they reassure us that that de novo low
cholesterol is not a source of concern
and therefore this can be extrapolated
for us to take reassurance that by
lowering people's cholesterol levels
we're not placing them at risk of non
cardiovascular disease but hint here on
this lady's results that makes me think
that this is a primary advantageous
situation rather than a low cholesterol
secondary to some other worrying
undiagnosed situation is that the low
cholesterol of which are associated with
intercurrent disease would usually be a
reduction in both LDL and HDL and as you
can see this particular lady the ACE
deals will sustain and that's really
what's led to the particular
exaggeration of the low LDL cholesterol
level and so look there a number of low
lipid conditions and wednes I've
highlighted here I guess it may be
particularly highlighted low HDL and on
the right-hand side you'll see that
we've been familiar for a long time with
some low LDL cholesterol conditions
first of all a condition called a liter
lipoprotein emia where the life with the
the Cascade of particles caring
triglycerides and cholesterol towards
the periphery the formation is inhibited
by lack of one of the participating
entities that is my chromosomal transfer
protein we have a different model of a
lack of these particles brought about by
abnormalities of apolipoprotein b and
the severity in those situations usually
tracks with the degree to which the fo b
molecule is disrupted its disrupted to
less than half its length then it's
going to start to infect the post
cranial metabolism as well but John down
the bottom I'll highlight a newer entity
that we've become aware of which is
deficiency of FZ notice pcsk9 extends to
proprotein convertase upland kicks
online and that's given an appreciation
of an extra dimension in cholesterol
metabolism and it's also gone on to have
some very useful clinical applications
so here again is their differential
diagnosis of low cholesterol
triglyceride map ov the complete lack of
the particles as i mentioned due to the
lack of the microsomal transfer protein
bringing about a visa like protein emia
or the more modest reduction in fov
particles thought about other mutations
in fo b and this final entity at the
bottom of the pcsk9 mutations I've put
up again the diagram of our LDL receptor
removing LDL particles from the
circulation and and having the LDL
particle catabolized in the lysosome and
you'll notice that the recycle
recirculation of the receptors for reuse
on the surface has been greyed out
because that reads recycling depends on
the absence of pcsk9 and when pcsk9 is
present it redirects the LDL particles
and the
said so that they said the whole
conflict goes to the life is owned and
not only is the LDL broken down but also
the pieces came home and also the LDL
receptor so we have a fine tuning if you
like of LDL receptor function and plasma
cholesterol levels and indeed
intracellular cholesterol and we learned
these notions from cases of familial
hypercholesterolemia in which we
couldn't find a defect in the LDL
receptor and we found that an effective
situation is arising from a
gain-of-function mutation in the pcsk9
leading to increased catabolism of LDL
receptors and the full familial
hypercholesterolemia picture and a bit
of lateral thinking said well it gives
too much is bad for you but enough might
be good for you and search was
undertaken for families in which there
were pcsk9 loss-of-function mutations
they were detected these were
individuals in which pcsk9 levels were
lower in fact the LDL receptors were
more prevalent in these patients their
LDL cholesterol levels were around about
thirty percent lower you can see this in
the comparison of two populations with
it without a pcsk9 loss-of-function
mutation in the left-hand panel panel
the right hand so the the left hand
white population with the mutation
presence had their cholesterol levels
shifted to the left but had around about
a thirty percent reduction in their LDL
cholesterol levels and over fifteen year
observation period you can see in the
right-hand panel but this provided them
with a ninety percent protection against
cardiovascular disease so so this was
extremely encouraging and he has in fact
been leveraged in order to provide a
novel form of treatment and amongst the
observations of those families through
into individuals who were detected to a
homozygous for peace
sk9 lots of function mutations and here
you see there to lipid profiles very low
cholesterol levels and extremely low LDL
cholesterol levels all of the
cholesterol that was prevailing was
still tied up with HDL cholesterol
rather than LDL so these two young women
had LDL cholesterol level similar to the
case that I showed you at the start
around the 15 milligrams per deciliter
that they were completely healthy they
had normal family reproductive function
they were high achievers in terms of
cognitive function they have no
musculoskeletal symptoms etc they
enjoyed what is essentially perfect
health and that really agrees with our
other genetic studies in pcsk9 knockout
mice which also have extremely low LDL
cholesterol levels they too have normal
fertility and development so here I
think is very strong encouragement that
very low LDL cholesterol levels achieved
by genetic or therapeutic means do not
present a long-term risk so rarer causes
dyslipidemia have led to some important
treatment discoveries and one such
condition pcsk9 deficiency has led to
novel antibody therapy which is a source
of excitement at the moment and extreme
cases of low lipid suggest that Lawson's
cholesterol is not harmful providers of
fat-soluble vitamin levels remain
adequate so okay well so we have now
another case of a bit thank you David
that's a very interesting concept we get
their fifth case which is a male again
middle-aged male but this time with most
abnormal lipids with a very high
triglyceride level as well as
hypercholesterolemia the LD the HDL
cholesterol is in is low and and and if
we can't calculate the LDL cholesterol
because of this high level of
triglycerides
so what do you think here in terms of
informing the general practitioner who
who who this is seeing this patient
affected look I think often there's a
lot of misconception about this I might
just quickly principal highlight but yes
it is unfeasible to calculate BL LDL
cholesterol using the Frida world
equation in this situation the
calculation should be limited to
situations in which triglyceride is less
than 4 millimoles per liter or which i
think is around about three around about
400 milligrams per deciliter if you do
the calculation of higher levels you can
end up getting some ridiculous results
and it's in fact if you did it in this
particular individual you would have a
negative results for your LDL
cholesterol because you'd be subtracting
a larger than the appropriate number and
of course they've met a ridiculous
result I think it would confuse and the
Wilbur our clinical colleagues but I
have seen those sorts of results
reported so it is important to identify
that LDL cholesterol calculation is not
not suitable in this particular business
not suitable in this particular set of
circumstances many air on the next slide
you'll a patient with a set of results
like this would probably have blood but
looks something like that and I don't
think lambs particular like handling
that sort of assessment for a variety of
reasons and just to flash through a
couple of concepts here the results did
include a cholesterol it was over 10 and
i think it's not terribly widely
appreciated that even though that total
cholesterol is high the LDL cholesterol
I think many people shimmer
be high when that is not the case it's
going to be very low partly because of
those exchange mechanisms that ancient
previously and and of course the this is
part of the reason why the feed world
equation is is not suitable in this
situation the second thing is of course
is likely to cause some artifacts you
often see delusional effects here where
the sodium level might be artifact
surely low you're really getting
displacement effects from the from the
lipids and the last thing is that with
these drastic results not experienced
clinicians are likely to make that
assumption and think that the LDL
cholesterol is still high and and have
concern about the risk of cardiovascular
disease were in fact the risk is
entirely different in this situation the
risk in this situation is one of acute
pancreatitis this has to do with our
concept of the blood supply of the
pancreas where the capillary network
through the pancreas probably allows a
little bit of backward diffusion of
pancreatic lipase as its produced for
exocron use and you can imagine that if
a tiny bit of pancreatic lipase leeches
back into a capillary where triglyceride
levels are so grossly elevated but it
will break down the available
triglyceride in the blood rather than in
the intestine and that the release of
free fatty acids will then increase the
membrane permeability leading to a
vicious cycle where essentially that the
patient starts suggest themselves from
the inside out so this mass spec
hypertriglyceridemia poses a risk of
acute pancreatitis a very hazardous
condition with a high mortality rate so
it's actually probably more of a medical
emergency that most of our other lipid
profiles would present
just to think a little bit about what's
going on what what's being disrupted
here is the process of extraction of
triglycerides from Troy Glaus Troy rich
particles both carlo microns and vldl
and so that usually requires lipoprotein
lipase acting with its cofactor echo
situ we can have genetic absence of
idlebury enzyme itself or the cofactor
which of course would lead to massive
hypertriglyceridemia as might be
anticipated this would often occur at
young age and so in the case of our
patient being 45 years old and this may
be being the first episode we've also
got to imagine some other circumstances
and the another circumstances make this
massive hypertriglyceridemia a more
common problem that it would be if it
was occurring purely on the basis of
recessive genetic disorders so probably
poly genetic factors lead to groups of
patients into them lipoprotein lipase
activity is diminished but not absent
and in most individuals if the
triglycerides removal lags behind and
they are exposed to an exacerbating
factor whether it be a high-fat diet or
the emergence of diabetes or obesity or
those sorts of things we eventually
reach a stage where the lipoprotein
lipase is fully saturated by the
available circulating troves right
therefore when the next meal comes along
the next batch of triglyceride just gets
dumped on top of that and we start to
see a backlog of triglyceride in the
circulation and indeed that will take
off in an exponential fashion so that
the triglyceride level merely reflects
the amount of fat which is being
recently consumed and so a previously
mildly elevated triglyceride of 3 or 4
millimoles per liter can suddenly
exacerbate up towards 10 20 40 70 a
hundred very high levels of LDL
cholesterol elf circulating
triglycerides sorry I gave you both
laugh representative figures in
millimoles per liter son
the words you your triglyceride level of
200 can suddenly take off the story
about 400 can suddenly take off to 1500
3000 4000 etc so in summary Mastiff
hypertriglyceridemia poses a risk of
acute pancreatitis Carla Carla microns
to assistive lipoprotein lipase
insufficient or saturated those poly
genetic predispositions to reduce luck
protein lipase activity making John
other genetic influences on lipoprotein
lipase opposed c2fo a 5 etcetera
laboratory artifacts may arise due to
the torpid turbidity and volume
displacement of fixham please Carla
microphone presence of particles present
in the circulation and so I think that
my biggest to our last case alright then
so this is a middle-aged woman again
who's this time is presenting after
she's already had a heart attack at some
stage and she's on therapy for
cholesterol lowering cholesterol and
she's getting some it seems to be some
effects as beneficial effects with the
target values that you have here be for
this patient be the same as for a
patient who is not receiving hasn't had
this this history David I think they
would be different I think they would be
lower and more aggressive in this case
in fact the target but I would have in
mind would be a target of less than 1.8
million monthly or a target of less than
70 milligrams per deciliter we've
recently completed a child called
improvement which proves the benefit of
itself agree hello David looks like your
phone problem these there oh I'm still
have speakerphone can you hear me her
David I'm adding trouble we're having
trouble lab okay I'll just pick up the
i'm using my hand said now is that any
better hello hello hello I mean yeah I
done I'm picked up the handset I didn't
do anything I think I can see there's
the bar circulating for reconnecting
hello
when continue on David I think we lost
our okay okay I'll stay on the hands it
might be best to the moment I've got a
circulating bar saying connecting but
you're right for me to go here decide
right yes okay we'll look just
continuing to highlight their patients
who have established symptomatic
cardiovascular disease usually do
qualify for more aggressive target
particular wig same target LDL
cholesterol levels here because that's
but what's being traditional the recent
improvement study which used more
aggressive treatment including as M I'd
hasn't showed a benefit in patients who
had LDL cholesterol levels down at 1.4
compared to 1.8 in the in the standard
treatment group and so I think there is
a possibility that target levels for
patients with cardiovascular disease may
be further reduced in the future and
with that in mind again I guess
treatment is going to be a little bit
more aggressive and in that process
people may raise questions about the
possibility of side effects and so
you'll see that this particular patient
has mild elevation of liver function
tests while the elevation of CKD level
and just I think also doing to try to
explain why the patient might have had
cardiovascular disease in the first
place I've just highlighted the
patient's got an elevated lipoprotein
little a level and so I'd like to maybe
look at these three issues so the first
point to make is that the benefit of
cholesterol-lowering i think is very
well established this is the cholesterol
trials collaboration showing the benefit
even in primary prevention so this is
patients who yet to have cardiovascular
events and therefore
or would be even more difficult in home
to demonstrate a benefit but the benefit
is clear their analysis of also large
numbers of patients also establishes I
think the placebo-controlled side effect
rates of statin therapy pointing out a
mild but important risk of new-onset
diabetes a modest risk of hemorrhagic
stroke but a but that's overshadowed by
the prevention of non hemorrhagic stroke
a really quite low rate of myopathy and
an even lower rate of the serious
rhabdomyolysis you won't see any mention
of liver function test abnormalities
there nor will you see any mention of of
liver dysfunction and I think recent FDA
analysis has been reassuring that even
when Stanton is used in the presence of
non-ideal liver function tests the
experience suggests that it is very very
unlikely that statins contribute to the
onset of long-term liver dysfunction as
a result of a hypothetical fact so
there's now a good level of confidence
for continuing to use statins in
situations like fatty liver disease etc
etc the point I made about the
lipoprotein little a is that I think
this is a an exciting area of laboratory
medicine lipoprotein little a is a
special fraction of the LDL cholesterol
it is distinguished by the presence of a
unique plasminogen like life a life of
protein and the whole entity known as
lipoprotein little a seems to be an
independent risk factor for
cardiovascular diseases maybe because it
may interfere with spontaneous
thrombolysis it may be
particularly likely to potentiate
atherogenic party processes where of the
opinion that levels in the top twenty
percent to thirty percent of the
population represent an additional risk
factor and that probably represents a
level above around about 500 milligrams
per deciliter or sorry 50 milligrams per
deciliter above about 500 milligrams per
liter and this impression has also
reinforced by Mendelian randomization
studies so lipoprotein little a I think
is a risk factor for for cardiovascular
disease I point out that it's not
actually reduced by statin therapy but
thankfully is now treatable with some of
our novel agents such as auntie pcsk9
antibodies again just reinforcing the
message that liver function test
abnormalities in conducts in conjunction
with statin therapy really progressed
liver damage and a point that Frank's
that mark the sufficient to cause
serious elevation of CKD is rare we do
however often see mile ck elevation in
the setting of statin therapy and indeed
in the in the general population so
maybe the just to sum up then just if we
come back to our bread and butter with
the tests total cholesterol is one of
the components of absolute risk
assessment if taken in isolation its
confounded with respect to
cardiovascular risk because it's
compromised by anti and pro atherogenic
lipoproteins and it's the starting point
for calculations that aim to quantitate
the amount of atherogenic lipoprotein
LDL cholesterol and increasingly non-hdl
cholesterol HDL cholesterol is a
continuing interest we're starting now
to think more about it thank Frank
elastics direct my methods involve
selective recognition of HDL cholesterol
and some of the early assays I think
we're a little bit affected in the
sitting of increased triglyceride levels
we should be used the idea that those
exchange processes we mentioned earlier
tend to slightly lower rates deal in
postprandial samples and finally fasting
triglycerides standardized standardizes
the calculation of LDL cholesterol and
defines levels for diagnosis and
treatment of hypertriglyceridemia
non-fasting levels may be a more
sensitive layers to take in
cardiovascular risk and
hypertriglyceridemia in general both
fasting and postprandial may influence
building or composition size and density
and of course very high levels pose a
risk of pancreatitis triglyceride may
steal as you I think appreciate by now
do tend to have an inverse relationship
with each other so I should conclude at
that point I'll just leave things open
for questions or comments and otherwise
I thank everyone for their their
participation and wish you will for the
rest of the meeting thanks thanks David
thanks for a great presentation before
we go into QA I just want to remind the
audience how to submit questions they
can type them in the QA the green Q&A
button there you click on that type in
your question and we'll try and answer
as many questions as we can here before
the end of the session so we'll just
give you a minute there to submit any
questions you might have
and don't be shy
okay or do you have any other comments I
just want to make the face Don look I'd
be happy to take questions in over over
the following period of time I think the
first slide had my email address and I
I'm just honored to being able to
participate and I realized that we are
speaking too many parts of the world I'd
love to hear other people's perspectives
and comments might have been from Down
Under and we're always aware that there
need to be local interpretations in that
indeed that's the one of the main
messages about absolute risk is that our
absolute risk calculators should be
harmonized to local requirements so I do
look forward to any further questions
that come through and otherwise I thank
you very much for this opportunity this
wishes to every other thanks again there
ok so this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April of 2016
and you'll be getting an email from lab
roots then we'll alert you when those
webcast is available for replay from on
demand and we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleagues you made
it miss today's event so until next time
thanks a lot you might